we call it the question man and I'm not
he Pastor Ortiz is the question man but
we answer your questions we'll do our
best to answer your questions every
night we'll try to answer them the very
night you have asked them
we don't know everything if we don't
know the answer we'll tell you we'll be
honest with you we'll find an answer if
it can be found in the Bible
there is something we request however
please do not ask questions that will
reflect on Persons or religions please
don't do that we want to be very
discreet in what we do and now to show
you how it goes we've collected a few
questions you have some don't you Pastor
let's go with them all right the first
question is it true that when a man dies
it just had to be because his time had
come
you know I have heard that all over the
world when you die your time has come I
was in the country of Brasilia and we
had an escort who took us up on top of
the Senate building and there was a
little narrow catwalk all the way across
and maybe 12 or 15 stories high to the
house building and the lady looked at me
and said are you afraid to follow me
across here
well you know men can't take that I said
of course I'm not afraid so I started
across the crazy thing is that when you
got halfway it did this
and it was frightening
in fact when I got on the other side I
out of the little prayer I said Lord if
you help me back across this thing you
won't have to answer this prayer again
ever
but there was something she said that
shook my confidence further she said
pastor a lot of folk are afraid but I
believe if you drop and you die your
time had come I don't believe that
the Bible says and here's the answer you
want the Bible says in Ecclesiastes
chapter 7 and verse 17 be not over much
Wicked neither be thou foolish why
should as thou die before thy died
it is possible to be foolish or Wicked
and die before your time if you get
drunk and go out on the highway drive
100 miles an hour hit a tree and die
don't tell me your time had come you
have been foolish next please
Pastor Brooks do you believe it is true
that if you are once saved
you can never be lost
that that really is a very serious
question I'll tell you why it is because
it is a very pervasive idea and has
become believed generally in Christendom
today that once you give your heart to
the Lord you cannot be saved the Bible
does not teach that there are many
things that are taught that are not
scriptural and I believe that unless it
is found here we are not bound to
believe it the Bible doesn't say that I
tell you what the Bible does say it
mentions backsliders
now the whole word would be obviated if
this idea was true that you once saved
and never lost there could be no such
thing as a backslider that means you
were once headed toward the kingdom and
you see it back
that's what it means in The Book of Mark
the the Apostle said in Chapter 13 he
said that he that endureth unto the end
shall be saved but here is a text that I
think will answer it very well second
Peter chapter 2 and beginning with verse
20. it says for if
after they have escaped the pollutions
of the world through the knowledge of
the Lord and Savior Jesus Christ they
are again entangled did you get that
these are people who have escaped the
pollutions of the world through Christ
but if they become a gain entangled the
Bible says and overcome the latter end
is worse with him than the beginning for
it had been better for them not to have
known the way of righteousness that
after they have known it to turn from
the holy commandment delivered unto them
verse 22 a very strong verse but it has
happened unto them according to the true
proverb the dog is turned to his own
vomit again and the sow that's a female
pig the sow that was washed to her
wallowing in the Maya strong and graphic
language a person who starts with the
Lord and turns back and becomes
entangled
it is hard to win them back to the Lord
and the Bible says they are like a dog
that returns to its vomit and a sow that
has been all cleaned up going back to
the mud hole no it's not true once saved
never lost you've got to endure by faith
you've got to endure by holding on to
Jesus you've got to endure by the force
and power of Prayer
you've got to endure by sheer will
surrendered to the will of God would you
say Amen if you believe that
thank you next please
Dr Brooks tell me will too much religion
drive you crazy
I
it depends on what kind of religion you
have
there are many religions but one
Christianity
and perhaps some of these others could
do it but not the word of God and not
Christianity would you say Amen there's
a favorite text found in the book of
Psalms it is the 19th Psalm and verse 7
and there it says the law of the Lord is
perfect converting the soul the
testimony of the Lord is sure making
wise the simple
knowing and believing and studying and
understanding the word of God makes your
mind Keena
two young men were in college I know one
he's a relative the other one was a
Caucasian friend and they both were
straight A students but one day they had
a very severe test
and the young man eat out a little bit
higher than my relative and so they were
friends he went to him he said tell me a
secret we both study we both understand
and yet on this one you beat me what is
your secret and the young man said
because you're sincere I'm going to tell
you and he reached up and pulled down
the word of the Lord it says the fear of
the Lord is the beginning of wisdom he
said I begin every day before I go to
class with the word of God you sharpen
the mind it comes alive students you'll
make better grades if you begin the day
with Bible study and prayer and you
don't need a prayer law to do that
is it true that money is the root of all
evil
I heard this on the news the other day
if you think money is the root of all
evil I'll take all that evil money away
from you
you know there are many things the Bible
is accused of saying and people do not
read it carefully the Bible doesn't say
that the Bible says that money is a
defense if you have money it will defend
you against hunger against nakedness
against homelessness and many other
things you need money the Bible doesn't
say that but then there are some for
whom money is most important more
important than their standards than
their convictions more important than
loved ones I read of a man who put a
bomb in his Sweetheart's luggage and put
her on an airplane so he could collect
the insurance
the Bible says the Love of Money
the love of money is the root of all
evil now have you got it not money but
the Love of Money when money becomes
preeminent in all of your affection then
money becomes your God and you are thus
corrupted prostitution means more than a
lady or a gentleman walking the streets
prostitution is the selling of virtue
for money or gain
if money then is more important than God
and doing his will if money is more
important than people then the Love of
Money lies at the root of all evil
Dr Brooks this person wants to know why
should Christians read and believe the
Old Testament wasn't that for the Jews
interesting let me answer it this way I
had a question like this not long ago
when Jesus was here
there was no new testament
let me repeat that when Jesus was here
there was no new testament at all
as a matter of fact I read that The Book
of Mark was probably the first of the
New Testament books recorded and that
was Psalm 22 years after the extension
so the disciples for 22 years after
Christ only had the Old Testament if
that's clear Say Amen now the Bible says
in second Timothy chapter 3 and verse 16
all scripture how much
old scripture is given by inspiration of
God and is profitable
profitable for what profitable for
reproof for correction for instruction
in righteousness all scripture in John
chapter 5 and verse 39 Jesus said search
the scriptures the understood subject is
you you search the scriptures for in
them you think you have eternal life and
they are they which testify of Me Jesus
said the Old Testament testified of him
there was no new testament when he said
that not only that but if you read in
the Book of John chapter 5 and verse 46
the Bible says had ye believed Moses you
would have believed me how many of you
ever heard of Jesus walking on the road
to Emmaus or immoral says some say how
many of you ever heard that Ray Jad the
Bible tells us about that visit he was
walking with disciples who didn't really
recognize him all they knew their lord
had been crucified and buried and they
were dejected and depressed and so full
of Darkness they didn't even recognize
Christ he went with them and as he sat
at meat with him the Bible says he began
with Moses he began where
and all the prophets and expounded unto
them the things which the scripture said
concerning himself
I like to put it this way the Old
Testament is the New Testament concealed
the New Testament is the Old Testament
revealed next please
Pastor how can we believe in God when we
have not seen him
the skeptic always asks that question
you better be glad you have it for the
Bible says you can't look on God and
live
by the way that's why we haven't seen
him now on the other hand you haven't
seen George Washington
or Abraham Lincoln
and I guarantee you believe in or about
them not having seen them the Bible says
the just shall live by what
faith faith is the substance of things
hoped for and the evidence of Things Not
Seen and the Bible says without faith it
is impossible to please God there is
great evidence that there is a God you
are looking at the evidence that there
is a God some 50 years ago I stopped
smoking stopped drinking stopped cussing
only God could do that for me
ladies and gentlemen God leaves evidence
in the things he has created in the
heavens they testify of his glory God is
God and we accepted by faith and one day
we have the promise we shall see him
face to face I remember a comment that
was made when a person said I don't
believe anything I haven't seen the
comment was you haven't seen your brain
I hope you believe you have one
Dr Brooks where in the Bible do we find
the secret rapture
the secret rapture we were talking about
the coming of Christ last night and I
like the way you put the question I can
answer it very succinctly and quickly
where in the Bible can you find the
secret Rapture the answer is you cannot
find the secret Rapture in the Bible
Jesus came before us and he said I will
come again and the Bible tells us in
several places let's take first
Thessalonians chapter 4 verses 16 and
17. it says the Lord himself shall
descend from heaven with a shout now you
don't shout when you want to be in
secret
he shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the Archangel
and with the Trump of God and the dead
in Christ shall rise first then we which
are alive and remain shall be caught up
together with him in the clouds to meet
the Lord in the air so shall we ever be
with the Lord when Jesus comes there's
going to be a racket
the old Negro spiritual used to say the
trumpet will sound so loud it will wake
up the dead like popcorn popping on a
hot stone Saints will come out of their
graves no secret about that not only
that there will be great and terrible
manifestations in nature the Bible says
mountains will move out of their places
islands of the sea will be swallowed up
the Earth will reel to and fro like a
drunkard and be removed like a cottage
there's nothing secret about the Lord's
return Revelation 1 10 Revelation 1 10
behold he cometh with clouds and every
eye how many
and every eye shall see him now you
don't have every eye looking if it's a
secret where did this idea come from
well I want to tell you that for many
years people did not believe in not talk
about the coming of Christ in the the
the nominal churches they didn't and
anybody who did was called the doomsdaya
well today with all the danger and crime
in the world people fear that we are
facing doomsday so Dr Billy Graham was
one of the first besides my own people
who began to talk about the coming of
Christ and then folk caught on to it and
they had to fix it
and they talked about Jesus sneaking
into town and stealing people away I saw
a bumper sticker that said in case you
see this car without a drive I I've been
taken in the Rapture now I don't make
fun of people who are sincere in their
beliefs but that is extra biblical it is
not based on the word of God when Jesus
comes it will be no secret next please
Pastor when I came in tonight I met a
young man he's nine years old and he's
got a hard question for you he wants to
know if UFOs are real
oh
well now now consider that UFO stands
for something very general unidentified
flying objects
unidentified
actually a a 727 that is seen in the Sun
at a certain angle it distorts itself
and creates an optical illusion and many
will see that and can't identify it so
to call it a UFO in that case it's real
there are many things that will be seen
as we get closer and closer to the End
of Time the Bible says there will be
fearful sights seen from Heaven I don't
doubt that
but if anybody tells you that something
landed and some little green ugly men
got out that looked almost like humans
they call them humanoids or humanids
that is not true
the only planet in Rebellion the only
planet uglified by sin is this one on
which we live all other creatures are
perfect all other creatures in God's
Universe are beautiful so much of what
you hear is ranked spiritism
fanciful imaginations giving vent and it
means nothing more than excitement to
them thank you for your questions
sir why are there so many different
denominations all claiming to represent
Christ thank you for this question and
we are going to answer it more fully in
a sermon that comes later on suffice it
to say right now the Bible declares
there's one Lord One Faith one baptism
have you ever heard that before
now the truth is that if there is one
Christ and one faith if all men
everywhere God everything which they
believe from the Bible then we would all
be alike
I hope you didn't miss that
if we got our faith from the Bible and
the Bible only then we would all believe
the same thing and practice the same
faith
this will be explored a little more
later on please wait for it next please
Dr Brooks you talked about wine last
night but didn't Jesus make it and drink
it at the marriage of Cana
Jesus made and drank it at the marriage
feast in Cana I don't have any doubt
about that when the Bible speaks of wine
it actually refers to more than one one
thing our language is a bit hamstrung if
you'll pardon that language we say we
love our mother we love our Lord and we
love our husband away the same word love
but they have actually different
meanings so in the Greek you have a word
for each one you know that well in the
Old Testament where you find so much
about wine and in the new the word for
wine in both languages refers to both
fermented and unfermented wine now Jesus
made
unfermented why
how do I know let me give you something
to reason on when grape juice I'm going
to use that because that was most common
in the Middle East when grape juice was
squeezed and sometimes sweetened and
allowed to sit exposed to the bacteria
in the open air it would begin to
ferment
fermentation is the process of
putrefaction
when I think ferments it's beginning to
rot
it is becoming corrupt is that clear and
so if you took the fruit and you beat it
up and and made a pope out of it and
allowed it to be exposed to bacteria it
begins to ferment to corrupt to rot and
then you squeeze that out and you let it
wait a while it becomes alcohol a
chemical change takes place and when
that happens it is Poison the Bible says
concerning that look not upon the wine
don't even look at it when it is red
when it giveth its color to the cup when
it moveth itself when the thing is
fermenting it boils Without fire the
Bible says when you see it begin to move
and there's no heat under it don't even
look at that why because alas it biteth
like a serpent and stingeth like an
error you read that in Proverbs 23
Proverbs 20 and verse 1 says wine is a
maca strong drink is Raging and whoever
is deceived thereby is not wise both
references the fermented wine but if you
read Isaiah Isaiah 65 and verse 8 it
refers to the wine that is in the
cluster
a cluster is a bunch of grapes grape
juice fresh that's also called wine in
the New Testament the early church
fathers referred to the wine that Jesus
made as amethysten the amethyst Stone
was believed to keep one soba and
therefore they called this wine used in
the early church amethysten you drank it
in many cases it represented the Lord's
blood in the communion service but it
did not make you drunk Jesus did not
make fermented wine and he never drank
it if he had done that he would have
contradicted his own counsel for the
word of God comes through him next
please
now Pastor my mother has lots of strange
dreams she believes there are messages
from another world could this be true
the Bible tells us in Joel Joel 2 and
verse 28 God said I'll pour out my
spirit upon All Flesh and amongst the
things that will happen as a result that
people of God will have dreams God has
spoken through dreams
Nebuchadnezzar received a dream and
couldn't understand it and Daniel was
set to interpret it and it is one of the
classic Prophecies of the Old Testament
but every time a person has a dream it
does not mean they have a spiritual
message from the Lord as a matter of
fact the Bible tells us in the Book of
Ecclesiastes chapter 3 and verse 5 that
dreams are the result of business
whatever you tend to concentrate on
whatever you are missing in your life
you often tend to dream about it I
remember being in a Land once overseas
for a long time and I enjoyed the
indigenous foods but the truth is I
began to want soul food does anybody
know what that is
I wanted to eat something I was
accustomed to and I got to the place I
would dream about string beans
and potatoes
and tomatoes
the themes which I had not had for weeks
so every time you have a bad dream don't
think it's God talking to you sometimes
it's what you had to eat
next week
this is an interesting question Pastor
why did God kick Satan out of heaven and
let him harass us here on this earth
when we are lower than the angels and
without any power all God needed was to
create a new Adam and Eve instead of
millions of people getting killed every
day in the Holocaust well that is an
interesting question and I would not
want to think that whoever wrote it
would presume to give God directions
in the first place in Heaven There Was
An Angel whose name was lucify
and sin was found in him it's called a
mystery sin cannot be explained he Not
only was an angel in heaven but a
privileged one he was called the leader
of the Angelic choir he was actually
next to Christ a covering cherub
attending the very Throne of God but
iniquity was found in him now we have
some Clues the Bible says his heart was
lifted up because of his Beauty and his
perfection
Pride goeth before fall Pride there are
six things that God hates yea seven and
the first one is pride pride seemed to
have been the thing that corrupted this
angel now make no mistake about it God
has always been the same God if he is
merciful today he was merciful then
if he is patient today he was patient
then if he is long-suffering today he
was long-suffering then we therefore
conclude that God gave to this Angel
every opportunity to repent and turn
around and turn away from his evil
course but the Bible says in Revelation
chapter 12 there was war in heaven his
Rebellion went that far actual physical
Warfare and he was cast out of heaven
God will not allow sin in heaven and
finally he was circumscribed to this
earth after the death and resurrection
of Jesus now why is he here why didn't
God destroy him all at once first of all
God is the ultimate wisdom we are not
wise enough to dictate to him or even to
make suggestions to him but I would
suggest several things number one
someone said to me one day Pastor it's
not fair long before we were thought
about Adam and Eve sin and therefore we
are paying for their sin and I replied
long before you were thought about Jesus
came and died to pay for a man's sin and
he promised power through the indwelling
spirit to keep us from sin we who are
submitted to Christ as his children do
have power would somebody say Amen to
that
and Satan cannot go beyond the limits
God has set before him
sin is running its course there were
questions that had to be answered and
ultimately the grand showdown between
Christ and Satan the forces of evil and
the forces of light will take place and
the ultimate Victory will come when
Jesus appears and from that time on as
you will see as we continue with this
series Satan will no longer have power
over anyone
and Christ is going to establish a
kingdom right down here
wherein dwelleth righteousness and he
said in the Beatitudes blessed are the
meek for they shall inherit what
some folk think you're going to heaven
and stay forever and heaven heaven
heaven no sir you're going to come back
down here the Earth was made for you if
you are saved the meat shall inherit the
earth and I long to live in it a world
without a devil next please
well pastor this question deals with one
of the big problems we hear about today
Pastor Brooks does the Bible speak
directly or indirectly about abortion or
The Unborn Child there is so much to say
about abortion today and we certainly
don't want to get into Political
discussions up here
the Bible says something directly and
indirectly first of all it says Thou
shalt not kill I cannot believe that God
is pleased with a three million babies
that are destroyed every year
there are people today who take it as a
matter of course they may go and commit
whatever sin they desire and then
destroy
the results through abortion
Now ladies and gentlemen I believe that
God considers a human being before he is
born read Isaiah 44 and verse 2. there
the Bible says from the womb God had
covered his servant one Prophet said he
was chosen from the womb not after he
was born and developed but from the womb
David had something to say about it in
Psalm 139 and verse 13 he said he was
covered from the womb and so I believe
that when life is formed in the womb
that we ought to respect life and this
business of multiplying abortions
uh is is one of the phenomena of the
last days as people in careless abandon
have cast off moral restraints now
having said that there might be times
when abortion is advisable if the life
of the mother is in danger it might be a
necessity not only that but in cases of
rape and certain other problems maybe so
but we are not here to settle that we
are here to look after our individual
selves make our own decisions based on
our convictions which ought to be based
on the word of God and we will always be
safe
this is our last question for this
evening Pastor what about a church man
who is unwilling to buy groceries and
feed his children and his wife
can that man be a Christian I don't see
how he can be
now now if the man is sick
then let's cut him some slack as they
say wouldn't you agree
if he's sick but if he is not ill if he
is capable and especially if he is
working and he is so selfish that he
will not feed his own family then the
Bible tells us something about that man
the Bible says that if a man will not
look after those of his own house let me
read it to you from First Timothy 5 and
verse 8 but if any provide not for his
own and especially for those of his own
house he hath denied the faith and is
worse than an Infidel that's what God
thinks of him and I think I concur as
usual with God